Hello, SumTV family. You're watching I'd
Like to Know, our Bible question and
answer program. We are so glad that
you're spending just a little of your
day with us. My name is CA Murray. I'm
in the company of Pastor Steven Boore to
my right, president and founder of
Secrets Unsealed Some TV and Pastor
David Salazar who gen is the general
manager of our Latino network.
Gentlemen, good to have you here both of
you.
>> Thank you. It's
>> a pleasure.
We love this program. It's it's fun for
us to study the word of God. If you have
a question that you'd like us to answer,
we invite you to send it your question
to tvsumsv.org.
That's tv.sumtv.org.
You see it right there at the bottom of
your screen. Uh send your questions to
uh that email address and we will get to
them just as soon as we can. Our
questions are our list is long so we
encourage you send your question in. Uh
many times we get questions that are
duplicates. So sometimes we don't answer
the particular question. We answer the
issue particularly when a number of
questions come in dealing with the same
subject matter. We just answer the
issue. So you may not hear your question
answered exactly as you send it. That
simply means that several people have
the same burden that you have and so we
try to answer uh addressing the issue uh
and not just the particular question. So
send them in and we will get right to
them as quickly as we possibly can.
Pastor Salazar, would you pray for us,
please?
>> Let us pray. Our gracious heavenly
father, as we come before you, we thank
you for giving us an opportunity to open
your word, to study, and to be able to
share what your word has in regards to
the questions that our friends who are
watching and listening have sent. And we
pray that as we answer these questions
that you will give us your Holy Spirit
so that we may answer according to your
word. And may the words that we speak be
in harmony with you and what you have
given us in your inspiration. And so
that those who are listening or watching
may receive an answer that will bring
them closer to you. We thank you for
your presence and for your blessing. We
pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. We are getting a number
of questions from the United Kingdom and
we're very very pleased that we're
getting so many questions from the UK.
All three of us have preached there uh
in times past and a wonderful place,
some wonderful Christians there. This
question is coming from Phil. It is
rather lengthy, so we'll take our time
and read it. Hello pastors and happy
Sabbath to you and your team. I love
your channel. That's good to hear, you
know.
>> Amen.
>> And thank you. Uh you are all doing a
great work for the Lord. Please could
you answer me about Joshua 10:13?
And uh Pastor Dave, if you would turn
there because I'm ask you to read that.
>> I have it right here.
>> Uh which has got me thinking about the
Lord's original creation, Sabbath day.
If the sun stood still and the moon
stayed for a whole day, that's all caps.
Uh let me say it. Let's say it was
Monday, then that means that the next
day was still the same day, Monday. And
if so, surely the next Sabbath or for
Joshua and humanity would have been a
day later than the usual one, which then
implies that time also stood still as
well, or did they just ignore that
Tuesday,
ignore that Tuesday was still Monday and
keep the usual Sabbath day? I am a
Sabbathke keeper and won't change it as
it just feels right. But this question
has me wondering. Okay.
>> All right. Let's read the passage. And
and by the way, it's one of my favorite
passages of the book of Joshua just
because of what it means, how the Lord
truly did amazing uh event there. I'm
reading from Joshua 10 12 just to give
the context to verse 14. And it says,
"Then Joshua spoke to the Lord in the
day when the Lord delivered up the
Amorites before the children of Israel.
And he said in the sight of Israel, son,
stand still over Gileon and moon in the
valley of Ahalon." So the sun stood
still and the moons stopped till the
people had revenge upon their enemies.
Is this not written in the book of
Jasher? So the sun stood still in the
midst of heaven and did not hasten to go
down for about a whole day. And there
has been no day like that before it or
after it that the Lord heeded the voice
of a man for the Lord fought for Israel.
>> Amen. Amen. So God did a very special
thing. This is a miracle. Uh and
miracles sometimes define uh defy rather
explanation and our understanding.
Pastor, I know you have a Ellen White
quote, I believe, that you want to uh
bring to us to help us understand what's
happening here.
>> There's one aspect that is not
negotiable
>> when we answer this question.
>> Yes.
>> The weekly cycle has never been broken
since creation week. That's not
negotiable. Mhm.
>> In other words, the weekly cycle of
seven days that we have today is the
same weekly cycle that existed at
creation.
>> Uh Ellen White has a statement in
testimonies to ministers page 135 which
tells us that uh the weekly cycle hasn't
been broken, but it tells us something
else really important.
Um it says there God speaks to the human
family in language they can comprehend.
He does not leave the matter so
indefinite that human beings can handle
it according to their theories. When the
Lord declares that he made the world in
six days and rest on the seventh day.
>> Mhm.
>> He means the day of 24 hours. Now here
comes the key point that we find uh in
this statement which he has marked off
by the rising and setting of the sun.
Now, here's the big question.
When the sun stood still,
there was not a new sunrise.
>> And it says the moon stood still, so
there was not another sunset on that
day.
>> Mhm.
>> So, in other words, you jump from one
day, you skip that day,
and you continue with the following day
because that day did not have a sunrise
and a sunset.
I don't know if you're understanding
what I'm saying.
>> She explicitly says the day of 24 hours
which he has marked off by the rising
and setting of the sun. There was no
rising and setting of the sun on that
extra day.
>> Yeah.
>> Which means that that day doesn't count.
>> Didn't exist.
>> Now there in the other statement from
Ellen White, Signs of the Times, March
20, 1879,
she tells us that that this cycle hasn't
been broken. She says the first week in
which God performed the work of creation
in six days and rested on the seventh
day was just like every other week.
>> The great God in his days of creation
and day of rest measured off the first
cycle as a sample for successive weeks
till the close of time. the weekly cycle
of seven literal days, six for labor and
the seventh for rest, which has been
here it is preserved and brought down
through Bible history originated in the
great facts of the first seven days.
>> The weekly cycle has not been broken.
>> Amen. So we have to do something with
that day,
>> that extra day, which by the way, the
text tells us it was 24 hours.
>> Yes.
>> No sunrise, no sunset. It doesn't count.
>> And and you know, pastor, there is this
other uh quote from spiritual prophecy
regarding this particular miracle that I
think uh sort of gives us a little bit
of a an answer that uh we can again
certify that there has not be a change
in the sense of what she'll say. I'll
read this is actually found in patrons
and prophets page 509 and this is in
regards to this particular event. She
says this mighty miracle testifies that
the creation is under the control of the
creator.
Satan seeks to conceal from men the
divine agency in the physical world to
keep out of sight the unwaried working
of the first great cause. In this
miracle, all who exalt nature above the
God of nature stand rebuked. In other
words, God has the authority over
creation.
>> Right?
>> That that day, as the Bible says,
there's not been a day before or since.
It's a
>> it's not it's not a day.
>> It's not a day. It's a particular moment
in time where either God paused it as as
a day or erased it. Either way, the
extra time, what I mean, erasing the
extra time, it doesn't really make a
difference because to God, that
particular day did not
>> interrupt the continuation of the cycle
that was established.
>> It had no sunrise and no sunset.
>> Yeah.
>> Bottom line, it wasn't a day. Exactly.
>> Because the day is marked by the rising
and setting of the sun.
>> Exactly.
>> Uh now, there's another issue which uh
which we can address here. I was once in
a conversation with u someone who said,
"Well, you keep the Sabbath. How do you
know the Sabbath today is the same
Sabbath of creation?"
And and then I said, I I said, "Okay,
let me ask you a question." Um,
what day of the week do you keep? Said,
"Well, I keep Sunday in honor of the
resurrection of Christ." I said, ' So,
you're saying that the Sunday that you
keep the day is the very day that Christ
resurrected?
Says, 'Yes.
I said, 'Well, if a Sunday today is the
same day that Christ resurrected,
then the Sabbath must be the same day,
too.
>> Exactly.
>> And then he looked at me, but he had a
comeback. He says, "But how do you know
that the Sabbath of creation is the same
Sabbath?" And I looked at him. said
because the Bible tells us that Jesus
created the Sabbath and he would not
have kept the wrong day.
>> Amen. Amen.
>> So the people look for all kinds of
excuses
>> or reasons
>> to not keep the Sabbath.
>> Yeah.
>> When they should simply take the text as
it reads.
>> Amen. And amen. I had the reading that
you just um had David is one I found uh
that it was a mighty miracle,
>> you know, and that sort of settled it
for me. One of one of the things uh that
you alluded to, Pastor Bor, in in the
book um
>> steps to Christ,
>> um Ellen White in her chapter on what to
do with doubt. Um well, she says, "Stop
it. Believe is the answer for doubt."
But the reason people do doubt is
because they don't want to do,
>> right?
>> And since you don't want to do, you find
excuses not to do. Uh so most doubt is
occasioned by an unwillingness to do
what God says to do.
>> Um this was a miracle. This was a
singular
>> occurrence of the power of God in
humanity. But we know that the seven-day
cycle has never been that which was is
and it has not been interrupted.
>> Uh so once you start with that premise,
now you got to find a reason. Well, the
reason was God chose to do this because
it's a miracle. Um and
>> that settles it for me. If you want to
do, God will give you plenty evidence to
believe and to do. If you do not want to
do,
>> he's not going to take away every doubt
in your mind. You've got to believe.
Believing is is our job uh to believe
and accept what God uh tells us is is
real and is true.
>> It was a miracle for us, not for God.
>> Not for God. Right.
>> Right. You know, we we've got to thank
the Lord for the spirit of prophecy.
>> Amen. Uh what a great gift.
>> Absolutely. uh to to um to the remnant
people of God to the church in all ages
that there are those who can explain
some things which are difficult to
understand uh but um uh have given us
the truth and the light as as expressed
in the spirit of prophecy. All right,
our time is moving along. Let's go to
our next question which comes to us from
James. This is all the way in New
Zealand
>> and we praise the Lord for that. Um,
Pastor Bo, would you read the question
for us, please?
>> Sure.
>> Uh, the question reads as follows. Do
the following quotes from the Bible
justify
consubstantiation?
Maybe I can explain what that means.
>> Uh, in the Seventh Adventist Church, we
believe that the bread and the grape
juice are symbols of the body and blood
of Christ. We don't believe that we're
eating Jesus. In other words, literally,
um, the Roman Catholic Church believes
in transsubstantiation.
That is that the bread is no longer
bread even though it tastes like bread.
And the grape juice is no longer grape
juice. It's the real blood of Christ
even though it tastes like grape juice.
In other words, the grape juice is no
longer grape juice or the wine is no
longer wine and the bread is no longer
bread.
Consubstantiation teaches that the bread
is still bread, but somehow the body of
Christ is in the bread
>> and that the the wine is still wine, but
somehow uh the the blood of Jesus is
found also in the wine.
That's why it's consubstantiation.
It is with the substance. In other
words,
>> so now that we've defined that, because
some people might say consubstantiation,
what is that?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, he gives the following text. 1
Corinthians 10:16,
the cup of blessing which we bless, is
it not the communion of the blood of
Christ? The bread which we break, is it
not the communion of the body of Christ?
And then also he quotes 1 Corinthians
11:27-29
where it says, "Therefore, whoever eats
this bread and drinks this cup of the
Lord in an unworthy manner will be
guilty of the body and blood of the
Lord.
But let a man examine himself, and so
let him eat of the bread and drink of
the cup. For he who eats and drinks in
an unworthy manner eats and drinks
judgment to himself. not discerning the
Lord's body. So those are the two uh uh
verses and passages that are provided by
James uh in the hopes of getting an
answer to this question.
These two texts and and to answer his
question as asked do not justify
transubstantiation nor
conssubstantiation.
Um
Christ said himself uh that this is a
symbol, you know, uh do this in
remembrance of me.
>> Um so he defined the parameters of what
this act did and what it means. And I
was trying to just find that that text
in in in Corinthians there. But while
I'm I'm scrolling here, maybe you want
to uh
>> I think it might be what 1 Corinthians
11 where
>> I have 1 Corinthians 10:16 if you want
me to read that verse. It says the cup
of blessing which we bless it is not the
communion of the blood of Christ the
bread which we break it is not the
communion of the body of Christ. So
that's this is what 1 Corinthians 10:16
say. Uh and uh I guess the next verse or
the next yeah is verse 11 27 and 20- 29
and I'll read therefore whoever eats
this this bread or drinks this cup of
the Lord in an unworthy manner will be
guilty of the body and blood of the
Lord. But let a man examine himself, and
so let him eat of the bread and drink of
the cup. For he who eats and drinks in
an unworthy manner eats and drinks
judgment to himself, not discerning the
Lord's body.
>> I think that uh what lays this theory to
rest
is a conversation that Jesus had with
the Jews in John chapter 6.
>> Jesus said something very revolutionary.
He said that unless you eat my flesh and
drink my blood, you have no life in you.
>> Now, if you simply took that which is in
John 6, the earlier parts of the
chapter, you would say Jesus is saying
that we have to eat his flesh and we
have to drink his blood.
>> And many of the disciples did take it
literally like that.
>> And and they got they got in fact the
people got angry.
>> They got upset. Is this guy teaching us
that we're supposed to be cannibals?
>> Yeah. You know, but Jesus clarified what
he meant.
>> Yeah.
>> Mhm.
>> You see, we assimilate Christ through
his word.
>> Amen.
>> In other words, his word uh contains
Christ in written form. And by studying
the word uh we assimilate Christ. And
Jesus when they uh when they became
upset with him because of what he said,
he clarified in verse 63,
>> he said, "It is the spirit who gives
life
>> the flesh profits nothing.
The words that I speak to you
>> are spirit
>> and they are life."
>> So Jesus makes it very clear that we
don't eat him literally. I mean, really,
what benefit would it be to eat Jesus?
>> Yeah.
>> It makes no sense. But eating his
assimilating his word.
>> Yeah.
>> And coming to reflect his character
through the word, that's the way that we
assimilate Christ.
>> Absolutely. Especially since this body
is corruptable. I mean, it's going to be
replaced. Doesn't make sense. There's no
benefit as you mentioned. And so the
idea of creating or taking these symbols
that Christ himself instituted as a
symbol of his blood, his body
>> as us to remember, do this in memory of
me, remembering what his sacrifice
meant. These are the symbols that are
taken for us to meditate, for us to
think deeply about. And in regards to
taking them unworthy, it's very
interesting because it's in the sense of
not making that communion with Christ,
not having the desire to put away sin in
your life, not willing to forgive one
another. All these things is what makes
you unworthy. And yes, you're taking
judgment by taking the lightly. So the
element is not about you know the the
the point of the verses that our friend
James is mentioning are not in regards
to uh proving anything about that
becoming a substance some of some sort
but truly is actually saying these are
the symbols that represent his death his
sacrifice and his coming and we are to
take them with the respect with the uh
fear of the Lord and and honor him by
being uh very uh remembering that this
is a sacred instit uh symbol sacred u uh
experience that we have to have in
church.
>> You know going back to that text that
you read
uh there were many additional disciples
who just sort of followed Jesus for
fishes and loaves and other kinds of
thing. When he made that statement um
there were some who got it there were
many who did not get it. Mhm.
>> And the upside we see we see in in John
6:66 there are many said this is a hard
saying we can't follow this. So they
turned away and Ellen White in
commenting on that says those who turned
away never returned to him. They walked
no more with him. So they walked away
for good because they didn't understand
what Christ is trying to say about
eating his flesh and drinking his blood.
They took it literally and they weren't
ready to receive the spiritual
application to his statement. So they
walked away and they never came back. So
the idea of consent, consubstantiation
or transubstantiation is refuted here in
John chapter 6 throughout that whole
verse.
>> Of course um I don't want to make a
point of this. It's coincidental.
But uh it's John 666.
>> Yes.
>> That speaks about the apostasy.
>> Yeah.
uh you know the probably those who put
together the New Testament uh should
have uh re re uh should have divided the
verses in a different way.
>> Yeah.
>> But it is interesting that uh and
everybody that's watching the program is
always going to remember John 666.
>> Yes.
>> Uh where it talks about apostasy. Uh so
um I don't think that uh we can in the
light of everything that the Bible says
that we can say that people are
partaking literally of Christ's body and
blood uh either with the uh bread or uh
and the and the grape juice or the wine
and with uh the bottom line is that they
are symbols. Mhm.
>> You know, another just briefly verse
that I think could help emphasize this
point is in Hebrews 10:10. It says there
uh speaking of Jesus, it says, "By that
will we have been sanctified through the
offerings of the body of Jesus Christ
once for all. There's no need for Christ
to be sacrificed
more than that time at at the cross.
There's no need for his body to become,
you know, a cons substance to with uh
with anything or trans sub uh substance
to um as as the Catholic church portrays
that that idea that is not biblical. He
sacrificed himself once there's no need
to sacrifice his body ever again.
>> And you know uh the striking of the rock
in the Old Testament, there are two
episodes illustrate this point.
>> Moses struck the rock the first time.
Mhm.
>> The rock represents Christ
>> and the rod striking the rock represents
the judgment that fell upon Christ.
>> Yeah.
>> That gave the water which is the Holy
Spirit,
>> right?
>> Um Moses struck the rock twice another
time.
>> Exactly.
>> And Ellen White tells us that uh and
common sense also that Moses ruined the
symbol that Christ was to be sacrificed
was to fall under the judgment of the
father for sin only once. and Moses
ruined the symbolism.
>> Well said.
>> May I encourage you to read John 6
beginning at verse 52? Uh the Jews
therefore quarreled among themselves
saying, "How can this man give us his
flesh to eat?" And then it kind of walks
you through. It's a very very important
chapter in understanding uh this idea.
And um Amen.
>> Good question. Well said. Thank you for
writing to us from New Zealand. Uh it's
good to know that our our footprint
stretches that far. very wonderful
country and um good Christian people
there. Again, our time has slipped into
eternity. Allow me in closing to wish
you both grace and peace through our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ. We'll see
you again soon. Bye-bye and God bless.